hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter fairy today
we'll be going for a deep dive into how
Lord Voldemort never figured out that
Severus Snape was a double agent whose
true loyalties laying with Albus
Dumbledore and the Order of the Phoenix
as revealed at the very bitter end of
the Harry Potter series Professor
Severus Snape was one of the most
successful turn cloaks to have ever
lived becoming a follower of Voldemort
and officially a Death Eater shortly
after leaving Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry zephyrus was a
wizard deeply entrenched in the world of
dark magic from a rather young age
before he became enamored with the dark
lord and his teachings however severus's
First Love was that of the muckleborn
wedge Lily Evans and so when Snape
learned of a prophecy that inevitably
sent Voldemort after the woman he loved
and set into motion a series of events
that would result in her death Severus
chose to alter his Allegiance and
instead work for the varied group of
witches and wizards set on destroying
Voldemort while pretending to remain a
faithful servant to the dark lord at the
very end of the series through a
devastatingly painful and sad Montage of
professors names memories alongside a
rather confused Harry we discovered that
shortly after this discovering that his
beloved Lily was in danger he called
back to his former Headmaster Professor
Albus Dumbledore in an effort to gain
his help in preventing her murder at the
hands of the dark lord however since
Dumbledore was ultimately unable to save
her from Death Severus was overcome with
the pain of her loss and decided to
dedicate the rest of his time in this
world to honoring Lily's Life by
protecting all that remained of her
existence her son Harry Potter this in
effect made him a Death Eater whose true
loyalties lay with Voldemort's sworn
enemies but of course since Voldemort
promptly disappeared after his
unsuccessful attempt to murder Harry as
an infant obviously there wasn't much
double Asian work to be done for an
entire decade after Severus changed
allegiances and as many Death Eaters
renounced their loyalty to Voldemort
After the Dark Lord's disappearance
zephyrus's reintegration into the
Wizarding World as someone who no longer
openly supported Voldemort was not
suspicious at least not to other former
Death Eaters but as the dark lord
regained his power and called upon his
band of loyal followers there were those
who doubted Severus Snape's loyalty to
Voldemort and yet the dark lord himself
saw no reason to question Severus after
his return to the Death Eaters keeping
him by his side believing him to be one
of his most Faithful Servants and
keeping him informed of his many plans
as he counted Severus as part of his
innermost circle of followers
but how is it that the wizard many
believe to be one of the most powerful
to have ever lived never managed to
figure out that Snape wasn't truly on
his side well I believe that the answer
to this question is actually a bit more
complex than one might first think to
which end I've put together a few ideas
I've had on the subject starting with
Snape used his occlimency Voldemort was
a skilled with Gilman who was able to
enter the minds of witches and wizards
without a wand or spell a skill that we
Muggles would interpret as the ability
to read minds although the Gentlemans is
a little more complex than that as it
allows you to delve into another
person's memories in addition to their
current thoughts Voldemort himself very
frequently used legitimacy to
interrogate his victims and followers to
ensure that he was getting a straight
and honest answer so of course it goes
without question that he would have been
using the same skill on Severus Snape in
order to determine whether or not he
could be trusted not only will the Dark
Lord have been able to tap into Snape's
thoughts when asking him a question he
also could have poked deeper into
severus's memories to understand if he
was telling him the truth about what had
happened while he was gone but as Snape
was also a skilled the Gentlemans he had
also developed the ability to perform
occlimency which is the act of blocking
another person from reading your mind
and searching your memories whether or
not Voldemort knew that Snape was able
to perform occlimency or not remains to
be seen but it would seem that he didn't
seem to notice or Canter look too deep
into the subject as he never questioned
Snape about this kind of ability or
skill which very tidally brings me to my
next Point Voldemort thought too highly
of himself the dark lord was in muggle
terms quite clearly a sociopath he was
extremely anti-social and very obviously
lacked any form of conscience this
Behavior also seemed to manifest itself
into his belief that he couldn't be
outsmarted he thought he was the most
powerful wizard to have ever lived and
that he was entitled the most powerful
wand to have ever existed the Elder Wand
on multiple occasions throughout the
series we see him behave in a way that
suggests he thought he couldn't be
outwitted or overpowered perhaps with
the exception of his encounters with
Harry Potter though I believe that he
simply thought there was no way that
Snape would have been able to deceive
him for if he did Voldemort would have
been able to tell it's also possible
that he didn't think that Snape was
capable of legitimacy or occlimency and
such skills were only achievable by
Great and Powerful Wizards like himself
in any case it would seem that Voldemort
may have never questioned Snape's
loyalty for one very arrogant reason he
underestimated him and in addition to
underestimating the abilities of other
witches and wizards there was also one
other major thing that Voldemort always
seemed to underestimate the power of
love Voldemort didn't understand love as
he demonstrated again and again the dark
lord didn't quite seem to grasp the
magical power of love from
miscalculating its protective abilities
when Lily sacrificed her life to save
her baby Harry to being unable to
identify how Lily's death would affect
Snape's loyalty Voldemort continually
overlooked how potent this emotion can
be and so while he may have known of
Snape's feelings for lily as Severus did
beg the dark lord to spare her Voldemort
didn't seem to recognize what those
feelings could lead to which in this
case was one of his most loyal followers
altering his allegiances to serve those
who stood against Voldemort although he
may have overlooked this considering
ring Snape killed his sworn enemy one of
the biggest pieces of evidence that
Voldemort would have looked to when
deciding if Snape could be trusted was
the fact that in the end he murdered his
biggest rival Albus Dumbledore now as we
later learn Snape killed Dumbledore at
the request of well Dumbledore as the
Headmaster was already dying from having
touched the cursed ring that had once
belonged to marvolo gaunt and had been
turned into a horcrux by Voldemort of
course the dark lord didn't know all
this and Snape's Act of Killing
Dumbledore atop Hogwarts astronomy Tower
would have resolutely shown him to be a
loyal unwavering Death Eater then again
maybe he did know but used it to his
Advantage finally there's the idea that
perhaps the Dark Lord did know West
nape's true loyalties lay it's not
completely out of the realm of
possibility that Voldemort who we've
already covered as being one of the most
powerful wizards of all time knew that
Snape was a mole and was simply using
this information for his benefit think
about it there are some several times
throughout the series that Voldemort
feeds false information to his group of
Death Eaters in an effort to fool Harry
Potter Dumbledore and the Order of the
Phoenix the dark lord even uses this
same tactic when he realizes that Harry
has been able to see into his mind
planting false thoughts to mislead Harry
Voldemort may have also recognized that
Snape was indeed providing him with some
credible Intel from the Order of the
Phoenix as how else would Severus have
been able to stay in such high standings
with Voldemort and the other Death
Eaters if he wasn't giving them some
information from the other side so even
if Voldemort knew that Snape was a
double agent working for the Order of
the Phoenix it's highly possible that
the dark lord wanted Snape to continue
to bring him bits of intelligence it
didn't matter to him that Severus wasn't
giving him full details what he was
bringing him was likely enough for him
to piece things together and stay ahead
of Dumbledore and with that we've come
to the end of another video what did you
think why do you think Voldemort never
figured out Snape's true loyalties
please share your thoughts in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel also be
sure to check out the content on Spotify
as well as extra content on my second
Channel Harry Potter Theory extra until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live